I think like okay the books you know
even in the books well how many all the
books come out when the movies were
being made no no everyone's fate of
their character wasn't even right
because if you knew that you ended up
with Harry
at the end like if you knew it from the
beginning you'd be like oh they've gotta
I mean this is a park that has to keep
going but you didn't know that how many
books were out for this time
I think
there were four or three definitely
three maybe four
and but no one told you what was gonna
happen didn't know
no so yeah I mean every time a book came
out you know I was there other bookstore
the day it came out like everyone else
like reading it and it was always hard
because I you know I loved the world I
loved the story I love the book but of
course you're not not going to be
reading the book and every time Ginny
pops up you're gonna be like oh what's
she doing kind of thing so it was always
quite a disjointed reading experience
because you kind of were reading it like
so the story and The Wider narrative and
then also just projecting oh gosh I
might have to do this now in in the film
and when yeah but when did you know
like did they tell you after the first
one that you're coming back
um yeah I think
um the first
I think so I think they knew they were
gonna make two I think that I can't even
remember now but I think they knew they
were gonna make two and kind of like
made everyone commit to the two but then
for a lot of the films it was just like
they kind of committed just one at a
time and then I think by the fourth or
fifth one it was like okay everyone you
gotta commit to the end now like you're
either in it or not which I get if they
didn't want someone being you know that
character and everyone associating that
actor with their character and then
suddenly not completing the full you
know eight films so
so yeah I mean I think it was pretty
obvious that they were gonna make them
all and they were very successful so
yeah did you uh
was did you remember anyone ever getting
fired or was supposed to play a part and
then they didn't continue it and someone
else besides obviously you know Richard
Harris passed away and so Michael Gambon
yeah took over it hey there folks it's
Michael Rosenbaum and boy have I got a
huge announcement for you this has been
a long time coming and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
um not that I remember
um you're in privy to that I wasn't
ready to that but there wasn't anyone
you know who came and then they sort of
disappeared
um that I was aware of right unless they
were very good at you know hiding there
yeah